[Applause]
I'd love to learn about these convent
yeah and the balls that they [ __ ]
have so I I'm wondering what's your
hierarchy of shittiness and on the show
okay what did you go for well I'm
thinking like I think Jeff was the
shittiest one Jeff is Jeff Lowe how
about Carol with the hideous because she
positions it as an animal rescue and
nothing about that seemed any different
Ginger's any zoo ok she's go and so my
girls have make like animal rights
person and a little bit of that has
rubbed off I feel a little bad for the
cats but generally speaking whatever I
just don't like hey this is a rescue hey
guys come pay money to watch whatever
and then you can look at the animals
also I'm making twenty five thousand
every week on face book and it's a
rescue but in reality it's just a zoo
and who played their employees of the
least oh they all their employees
nothing they're volunteers are
volunteers Carol Carol Carol paid the
least
that's a Colton it is a cult and she
looks like a cult [ __ ] this is the
other thing I was gonna say my girl hops
and my girl hops in like C's episode six
or something she's like what big cat
rescue I know that that's where there's
this IG girl yo Ventura who's always
like petting baby tigers and [ __ ] and
she was like I think your Venture is
always going to petting the Tigers so
your whole [ __ ] point is you
shouldn't be allowed to pet these
animals but there's this IG thought who
can just come in and pet him whenever
she wants okay so your PR you're doing
the same [ __ ] you don't think is
different and we saw the videos where
she used to be a breeder yeah yeah
there's just no breeder is like oh I
don't know how to make this business
work so let me just go against everybody
else and do it into that point if you
noticed and they they had a little
snippet of this at the end of the final
episode you know a lot about people
based on their intentions when they
start right like we all start comedy
we're very pure yeah right and then
certain things might get in the middle
of it money gets in the way reality kind
of gets in the way reality gets in the
way whatever it is but when you start
you're actually really pure we had
hominy right when Joe started there's a
little snippet there's an old
black-and-white here it's where he goes
because you know these animals are only
supposed to be in Asia and India and you
know we got a controlled breeding and
you know yeah there's a little snippet
of him because he started pure right
yeah and we'll get to why these people
like are drawn to animals in general but
like there was a real purity to him
Carroll started impure impure yeah
yeah and she found a mask for that
impurity I think with Joe it was almost
like the ring remember Lord of the Rings
like the more you get addicted to the
rehab more harder yeah yeah and I think
that's what happened it's like all of a
sudden you got 20 [ __ ] Tigers that
need $10,000 month worth of food you got
I gotta find a way to feed these
[ __ ] so you do the cub petting
and then you do it more and more it
becomes more and more normalized yeah
you're making more money and why not and
what's also interesting is they talk at
the end everybody could go right now
they got information Joe exotic
snitching on everybody everybody's in
trouble except this [ __ ] she's deal
she's [ __ ] Marlo in the wire yes I'm
done I'm clean she's she got she's a
criminal like master husband percent
killer you think why no doubt I mean
it's just so convenient and she
benefited so greatly like she had a
motive she had like a way to do it and
the will that said upon death or
disappearance you probably explain it
better but in her will essentially or
the will she was married to this guy
made to a multi-millionaire
multi-millionaire many different
business ventures marriages falling
apart Merrick but he was also interested
in in the animals first yes right and he
liked these exotic animals and then they
both started to kind of get into it
together and he saw it as a business
with the cub breeding he want to do it
in Costa Rica marriage starts a fall
apart
he starts to get concerned he's like oh
this [ __ ] might kill me like yeah he
starts to tell his try to file a
restraining order he files a restraining
ready to kill him and he tells his
assistant yeah hey if anything happens
to me release this right and what was
that was in there as a will attest
or something like that that's right yeah
last rites you know if he goes if
anything happens to me release this and
it was him asking for a restraining
order from his wife that was denied
because you can't give a restraining
order unless there's an actual threat
you said I'm gonna kill you saying
you're gonna kill you is allowed because
it's freedom of speech you're allowed to
say that no son maybe if you watch it
you'd like it you [ __ ] listen for one
[Laughter]
so restraining order so streaming or
everything that the husband right before
he goes to Costa Rica he's about to go
to Costa Rica to do this like huged
thing where he wants to like and breathe
these cups maybe take the whole zoo and
take it down there where it's much more
legal or it's just not illegal yet
because I don't know about the [ __ ]
brand new country so he she basically
kills him
right when he was about to separate her
from all his wealth yes it kills him and
then there's his [ __ ] will that's in
a lockbox in the assistants office yeah
the assistant is not allowed access to
her office Carol and her [ __ ] lawyer
whoever it is are in the office
overnight they remove the Wills she goes
the next day there is no will they're
like this is so [ __ ] blatant that he
killed that she killed this man [ __ ] and
all of a sudden whereas the assistant
had power of attorney that wasn't a new
document saying Carol has my power of
attorney and power of attorney explain
what that means
I can speak on your behalf whether
you're there or not if I give you my
power of attorney you can go into my
bank account and be like hey I have his
private attorney give me all the money
and what is the new we'll say no it's
not a new will five years after
someone's death you can declare them
five years after someone's disappearance
you can declare them dead yeah okay so
five years and one day yeah she says I
am the beneficiary the sole beneficiary
in this will she cuts his first family
out kids out wife out whatever also in
the will its
head upon my death or disappearance all
my assets go - it doesn't say done
really it just says it's just here
that's the first line because she could
have faked his death or something yes
but instead she had to fake his
disappearance
what kind of will says if I disappear
oh my worried about disappearing life
have I been worried about disappearance
yeah you should have seen his reaction
of magic earlier or reappearing we're
guessing a goddamn card but seriously
it's it's a specific and absurd thing to
say Yeah right
my anticipate like it's so obviously
blatantly her and I think the document
tries to make it obvious and blatant
yeah and even through that you're like
how the [ __ ] has the FBI not
investigated this at all the creepiest
part is however Hearst her excuses oh
remember so they show the clip from like
the 90s and she's like yeah last thing
he said to me was get the truck ready
and like the the verb the verbage is
exactly the same yeah get it ready early
earlier early in the morning and then
she says it like on the interview with
20 years later
yeah she's like yeah he told me he was
gonna get up early early early in the
morning and like the same exact like
word-for-word creepy but she's a
murderer so she decided what her excuse
was gonna be decided the verbage and
stuck to it completely point is not a
memory it's a written like these
memories change yeah that's a written
dialer those are the best criminals if
your story never changes you can't get
caught so that's the other thing they
say about like criminals right it's like
or actually not criminals about innocent
people innocent people don't remember
what they're doing when crimes were
committed yeah because it was a regular
day it's a regular day they say innocent
people are the hardest people to defend
because if I say hey what were you doing
last Friday and you go at 11:30 a.m. I
don't know I didn't have a specific
thing I'm like oh so then how the [ __ ]
you have an alibi yeah yeah how the [ __ ]
you have a lot of times not even last
Friday a lot of times it's like what
were you doing three months ago yeah
yeah did you make some [ __ ] up that
might not even be accurate do you really
think did if I go two months ago what
did I say to you at 11:30 you're gonna
make oh you said there'd be there early
early
really yeah you're gonna remember the
exact sentence Cinco that's why she's
top dog Adam okay he's number one number
two Joe I like Jeff no Jeff Jeff more
Jeff why but Jeff he was like you knew
who he was he was already a criminal
like he just looks like he wears
affliction no exotic looks trustworthy
joke again you wouldn't give it to ya
[Laughter]
looks more friendly than Jesse looks
more friendly Jeff I like Jose limp
better than Jeff's yeah Jeff's walk but
I'm saying in terms of trustworthiness
neither one of them looks like a guy you
want to do business with Jeff was just
[ __ ] people over left and right and
left and right and I guess Joe was doing
that too maybe Jeff just had zero
charisma so you're like [ __ ] this yeah
because he [ __ ] up in Vegas early yeah
like you know Joe had to scam going on
for it yeah maybe you're right maybe I
was cut I was more like conned by Joe so
I'm my guy he's not as bad because I put
him forth I put it Jeff then doc then
yeah like Doc so I like his dog I like
doc okay doc is interesting doc is cold
that's the think cold and polished in
Jena solace you know it's almost like he
was the only person that wasn't broken
him and Jeff also that's another thing
you could see how Joe was broken early
on an episode one they said Joe says the
story him coming out to his father his
dad makes him shake his hand in front of
his mom to say when I die you will not
be in my funeral
and that guy's broken from then on yeah
most these people were broken
Jeff was not broken doc was not broken
Carol's just out of her [ __ ] mind I
think do you think Oh Carol's broken
story yeah I mean I want to get into
that and maybe
let's just go through the rankings and
then we'll get it here but uh doc was
interesting because doc has done
something I'm curious your take on this
but like you often see like white people
grab onto Eastern philosophy yeah and
then well I mean you see you guys do it
too but like I use the philosophy as
like a manipulation yeah yeah because
apparently is very effective to people
who are empty Eastern philosophy feels
[ __ ] empty people love well yeah I
remember what my brother was going
through really hard time he got into
Osho yeah
do you remember that like I think you
would know Osho Byron he's talking about
Hinduism stuff yeah okay Wow yes Osho's
the guy that blahblah country it's
another one that I wasn't as into
Netflix the Russian Ishii people they
were all dressing like the reds and
pinks who was out in was it Oregon it's
just vegans in the 70s but it was a no
that's a different one that was an
Indian guy I was in India guy so well so
is Virginie she yeah right so uh so like
he kind of times into this [ __ ] you know
what it is and maybe it happens in India
I don't know if it is but like maybe the
type of person that comes to America is
willing to do whatever the [ __ ] it takes
interesting to win he's willing to
sacrifice whatever the doc was born here
and he did the same thing short because
like I think he's bred within it but
like are we having this discussion I
can't remember but there's something
about the people that come here like all
of our parents that decide to come here
yeah like that immigrated here made a
choice to just leave their [ __ ]
families mm-hmm and never see yeah we
talked about we talked about some
podcast so there's a little [ __ ] yeah
psychosis going on there right yeah my
theory though cuz I'm watching this and
I'm watching this guy like pervert my
religion and whatever and I'm thinking
about wild wall country or whatever was
called yeah and I'm thinking about this
[ __ ] yoga guy who's doing the hot
yoga Bikram and [ __ ] everybody and
I'm like why are these people not the
manipulators the manipulations getting
rejected by everybody that was the
saddest part of the beat from
documentary
[ __ ] them easier to rape an idiot yes
usually if you're a cult leader yeah you
could get some [ __ ] right like this but
girl after girl is like I was like nah
that's now I actually want to watch this
document already this guy's get rejected
like it
[Applause]